y
[Música]
hola bienvenidos al segmento kobe 19 de
la semana en américa el espacio de
france 24 en que hacemos un repaso por
las noticias más destacadas que tienen
relación con la pandemia del cob y 19 a
continuación les presento los
principales temas que vamos a tener en
esta emisión
vamos a hacer una actualización de la
situación en los países andinos en
colombia ecuador perú y bolivia hay un
común denominador y es el aumento de los
casos de kobe 19 y también el arribo de
una posible nueva ola de contagios por
eso urge avanzar en la vacunación
veremos con nuestros corresponsales cómo
está la situación allí este aumento de
casos tienen relación con ese anuncio y
también esa advertencia que emitió la
organización panamericana de la salud la
ope ese que alertó sobre un aumento
considerable de casos en todo el
continente americano cuando la mayoría
de los países están eliminando las
restricciones ante el buen ritmo de la
vacunación que podemos hacer para
contrarrestar el aumento lo veremos en
unos minutos ya de alerta y también
expectativa a nivel mundial por el
aumento de casos de la llamada viruela
del mono que es originaria de áfrica es
una enfermedad que no es de alta
transmisión entre los humanos pero que
tanto riesgo representa la respuesta en
nuestra consulta con el doctor pérez
también hablaremos del aumento de casos
en eeuu
y de ese tardío pico de contagios que
está presentando corea del norte vamos a
comenzar y lo vamos a entonces con un
repaso de las cifras veamos como
avanzaron los números relacionados con
la pandemia en algunos países de nuestro
continente les vamos a mostrar cifras
registradas de casos y de fallecidos en
los últimos 28 días vamos a comenzar en
el norte en canadá allí en los últimos
28 días han sido reportados más de
165.000 nuevos casos de kobe 19 y más de
1900 personas han fallecido en eeuu los
casos superan ya los 21 mil 200 en los
últimos 28 días 600 personas han perdido
la vida en ese país en méxico los casos
ya superan los 20 mil 800 el número de
fallecidos 500 y vamos a finalizar en
brasil en donde los casos reportados en
los últimos 28 días superan los
371 mil y los fallecidos se cuentan ya
por más de
es momento para nuestra habitual
consulta con el doctor carlos eduardo
pérez él es médico infectólogo y nuestro
asesor científico aquí en france 24 los
saludamos él se encuentra en la ciudad
de bogotá doctor como siempre un gusto
tenerlo aquí en el programa y comencemos
despejando primero doctor esas dudas que
hay en torno a la viruela del mono hay
preocupación por la aparición de estos
casos en eeuu y en europa cuál es la
diferencia con la viruela tradicional
recordemos santiago que la viruela es
humana es una enfermedad que ha sido
erradicada del mundo y declara así desde
los años 80 eso quiere decir y es la
única enfermedad infecciosa que con una
vacuna se ha eliminado su circulación
del planeta estas son familiares digamos
los similares virus similares que
recordemos que esta familia de virus de
estas viruelas comparten en los animales
y en los humanos ocasionalmente por eso
se llaman zoonosis cuando se transmiten
de animales a hombres esta viruela que
es éste monkeypox que es de los simios
se han aparecido brotes desde 1970 muy
segmentados sobre todo en poblaciones
africanas lo que llama la atención es
que si bien es una enfermedad de baja
indulgencia han aparecido casos en
europa y en otras regiones en una forma
como invertir un poco en poco tiempo no
revierten mucha gravedad se diferencia
que es menos letal pero todos somos
susceptibles a poderla suceder sin
embargo las transmisiones mixtas doctor
precisamente será mi punto el que quería
preguntar a continuación la
transmisibilidad o la capacidad de
contagio entre los humanos es muy pero
debemos preocuparnos por esta enfermedad
qué cuidados debemos tener para
prevenirla
yo creo que no debemos preocuparnos
debemos estar atentos esta es una
enfermedad que se transmite mucho más
por el contacto directo y diré diferente
al joven que él es una transmisión por
aerosoles que desea hacer pocos metros
está se evita una cercanía y sobre todo
cuando la persona tiene las lesiones en
la piel donde ese exudado puede ser
infeccioso es detenerlo en la monitoría
en control pero no es preocupante y no
tenemos que hacer mucha alarma sino
estar atento a lo que dicen las
autoridades para las vidas que tengamos
que hacer en caso de detectar algún caso
doctor cierro este tema de la viruela
del mono lo vamos a seguir desarrollando
en futuros programas conforme vayamos
teniendo más información sobre este tema
paso a preguntarle algunas de las
preguntas que nos hacen los televidentes
a través de las redes sociales y alguien
preguntaba ya tenemos dos dosis de la
vacuna en algunos países hay a esta
tercera y cuarta dosis de vacunación que
serían las dos dosis de refuerzo cuántas
veces se puede padecer de kobe 19 a
pesar de tener cuatro o tres dosis
recordemos que esta vacuna previene la
enfermedad grave pero no corta la cadena
de transmisión por eso es importante la
revacunación y por otro lado el blues
sigue notando sigue cambiar lo siguen
habiendo sus unidades sus variantes que
nos va a infectar el colon al alumno se
va a eliminar estamos en la fase
endémica hemos dicho es que va a
permanecer en el tiempo que su letalidad
va a ser mucho más bajita es decir que
no va a matar a muchas personas y que
entre más cobertura una menos para que
haya enfermedad grave pero ahora está
muy lejos de eliminarla transmisible
cuántas veces nos puede dar no podemos
saberlo pero definitivamente si no
estamos vacunados y nos contagiamos la
prohibida enfermedad grave va a ser muy
alta y en cambio si estamos vacunados no
vamos a tener esa probabilidad tan alta
y por eso es que debemos reforzarse
probablemente cada seis meses o cada año
con una vacuna de éstas hasta que
logramos identificar una vacuna
universal
doctor pasó a preguntarle ahora por los
avances que hay para
en cuanto al tema del cob y 19 en
algunos científicos están hablando de un
test de orina para poder detectar
anticuerpos contra el hobbit 19 que
tienes todo innovador en que beneficia
los procedimientos médicos o de
detección de personas que ya han sufrido
el coronavirus
y entonces están encontrando su forma de
detección más rápido tanto del virus
como en la respuesta inmunológica en la
orina se han encontrado y permiten
digamos que en alguna forma facilidad
para poder identificar personas
expuestas a este virus sin embargo este
avance se hace enfocado hacia el
diagnóstico y también hay avances en
cuanto a tratamiento hacia nuevas
vacunas y por eso este desarrollo rápido
que se están haciendo alternativas va a
ser que se minimice la enfermedad pero
es distinto de eliminar la enfermedad
que va a convivir con nosotros unos
buenos años siguiente punto de la agenda
doctor la vacunación tal parece que las
vacunas nasales podrían ser la clave
contra el kobe 19 porque que tienen de
diferente estas vacunas en cuanto a el
dinamismo que puedan tener dentro del
organismo
como lo mencionaba anteriormente las
vacunas de primera generación no
eliminan la cadena de transmisión al ser
estas vacunas de una aplicación local
nasal cortaría la cadena de replicación
porque evitaría esa estado importador
que tiene la persona para poder
transmitir el virus esta es una forma
innovadora de hacer vacunas y hay
algunas vacunas ciertas nasales para
influenza pero estas vacunas podrían
hacer una reacción local más vigorosa e
impedir la cadena de transmisión y por
eso sería una alternativa no solamente
para controlar la enfermedad grave sino
como mencionábamos anteriormente
controlar la cadena de transmisión y
evitar eso si la propagación y la
reinversión en el futuro es una
estrategia muy interesante y ya están
los estudios clínicos muy avanzados este
tipo de vacunación bueno esperemos más
adelante tener más información y
desarrollo en torno a estas vacunas
nasales doctor para el cierre el kobe
largo siempre en todos los programas
destacamos algunos de los problemas que
deja el kobe largo en este caso nos
preguntaban por el cansancio crónico y
la fatiga extrema porque el cuerpo queda
con esta sensación ya sabemos que es una
enfermedad inflamatoria pero que es lo
que le produce al cuerpo esta
prolongación del cansancio
al parecer esa respuesta inflamatoria
que es tan aguda en algunas personas
sobre todo en personas que tienen
infecciones severas es persistente la
inflamatorias como si el virus e hiciera
un switch para que la respuesta
inmunológica se disparara y esa
respuesta inflamatoria fuera persistente
del tiempo y tal vez el síntoma más
frecuente que vemos en el post con esa
sensación de fatiga es ganó de impedir
realizar algunas actividades o si se
realizan la persona se siente y se cansa
más rápido es una entidad inflamatoria
persistente en el tiempo la que parece
ser responsable y que activa el sistema
y
está contra el sistema osteomuscular y
por eso genera esa sensación de
debilidad todavía no sabemos cuáles son
esas alternativas de tratamiento pero ya
estamos identificando los factores debes
muy probablemente en unos meses tengamos
una respuesta para ofrecerle este tipo
de pacientes quedamos atentos entonces a
esa respuesta doctor muchísimas gracias
por esta consulta y gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa vamos ahora
a más cifras ahora destacamos el avance
de vacunación en nuestro continente les
vamos a presentar el número de dosis
aplicadas por cada 100 habitantes en
algunos países de américa vamos a
comenzar en el extremo norte en canadá
en donde ya han inoculado 54 27 dosis de
refuerzo por cada 100 habitantes en
méxico la cifra alcanza a 40 69 dosis de
refuerzo nos vamos ya un poco más hasta
el sur argentinas allí han sido
aplicadas 50 0908 mejor dosis de
refuerzo por cada 100 habitantes y vamos
a finalizar en brasil en donde la cifra
alcanza
43,43 dosis por cada 100 habitantes
eeuu también está registrando un
incremento considerable en el número de
casos de contagio se esperan que las
cifras aumenten debido a la llegada del
verano en el hemisferio norte dos
estados son los más críticos mam en sala
está en la ciudad de washington y nos
cuenta más detalles de cómo está la
situación allí mamen muchas gracias por
acompañarnos hoy ya qué se debe este
repunte de casos el presidente by dénia
anunció también un reparto de mayor
número de pruebas para hacer un
diagnóstico temprano y agilizar un poco
la situación
si los casos en eeuu vuelven a subir
según las autoridades sanitarias un
tercio de los estadounidenses viven en
zonas donde ahora se encuentran en
riesgo alto de contagios y por eso
recomiendan volver a utilizar la
mascarilla en espacios interiores algo
que aquí ya ha dejado de hacerse hace
bastante tiempo ahora mismo los
contagios están subiendo pero sobre todo
están subiendo las hospitalizaciones que
eso como recordarán es lo que más
preocupa ahora mismo a los sanitarios en
los que se está basando el baremo para
ver si la pandemia está mejor o peor las
hospitalizaciones y en las muertes pues
bien las hospitalizaciones han aumentado
un 19% en tan sólo una semana hay 3.000
nuevas hospitalizaciones diarias por
kobe 19 en el país la buena noticia es
que de momento las los fallecimientos
por kobe 19 siguen manteniéndose bajos
los dos estados que más quemas más
alerta más contagios y más
hospitalizaciones tienen ahora mismo son
precisamente en esos dos estados la
pandemia pegó más fuerte al principio
que son california y aquí en nueva york
hablas de el aumento de las
hospitalizaciones particularmente en la
ciudad de nueva york allí el alcalde
local dijo que a pesar de este panorama
no va a reponer las restricciones
ciudadanas
sin nueva york es uno de esos estados
que esta semana ha pasado de alerta
media por hospitalizaciones alerta alta
porque las hospitalizaciones aquí
también se han disparado así como los
contagios el comisionado de salud ya ha
dicho que dependerá de los ciudadanos si
podemos volver a un nivel bajo o no en
esta pandemia esta misma semana el
alcalde de la ciudad eric adams ha
anunciado que se repartirán 16 millones
de kits de pruebas caseras en los
diferentes hogares neoyorquinos justo un
anuncio que ha coincidido precisamente
con el del presidente joe biden que a
nivel nacional también ha dicho que se
seguirán distribuyendo más kits porque
es clave para poder erradicar esta
pandemia el alcalde de la ciudad de
nueva york eric adams también ha dicho
que de momento no va a imponer
restricciones ni se van a cerrar
establecimientos ni se va a volver para
atrás porque está avanzando esa
recuperación económica de la ciudad ha
dicho que no se va a imponer de manera
obligatoria el uso de la mascarilla pero
recomienda su uso en interiores algo que
también recomiendan los centros de
control y prevención de enfermedad esta
sería la quinta ola que vive la ciudad
de nueva york desde que comenzó la
pandemia una quinta ola que comenzó a
finales de marzo
también también destacado esta semana el
anuncio de la fed que aprobó una nueva
vacuna para ser utilizada entre los
menores de edad que más anuncios dieron
las autoridades allí
si esta semana la agencia del
medicamento estadounidense que se conoce
como la fd ha autorizado la vacuna de
refuerzo en niños de entre 5 y 11 años
la vacuna de refuerzo de facer porque lo
ha hecho pues bien pzifer hizo esta
petición de uso de emergencia de esa
tercera dosis a finales de abril porque
según sus estudios esa dosis permitiría
reforzar la protección hasta 36 veces
más en este tipo de población
comprendida entre los 5 y 11 años además
desde el departamento de salud de nueva
york había varios informes varias
investigaciones que apuntaban a que
estos niños se habían perdido fuerza la
vacuna de facer había perdido fuerza en
estos niños cuando llego omicron así que
esto ha sido una muy buena noticia por
otro lado también tenemos que decir que
moderna está esperando esa autorización
para administrar una segunda vacuna de
refuerzo sería ya la cuarta de moderna
en la población mayor de 18 años pero de
momento todavía sigue a la espera esa
autorización
mari carmen mamen sala muchas gracias
por este reporte nuestro corresponsal en
la ciudad de nueva york hoy informando
nos desde la ciudad de washington la
capital de estados unidos vamos a
colombia como en muchos otros países de
la región hay un aumento de casos
importante en ese país que prácticamente
ya regresó a la completa normalidad para
conocer más detalles nos acompaña aquí
en el estudio santiago ariztía
periodista de la redacción de france 24
precisamente en bogotá en la capital
colombiana santiago gracias por
acompañarnos hoy en el programa aquí en
kobe 19 y bueno hablamos de cifras
colombia reporta un aumento del 24% en
el número de los casos que lo que sucede
así es y fue anunciado de manera oficial
santiago las autoridades colombianas han
alertado como evidencia sobre un
crecimiento de casos de coronavirus en
las últimas cuatro semanas un aumento
que llega al
24% y este incremento obedece a varios
motivos no primero hay elementos como
las restricciones que se eliminaron no
como la del uso de las mascarillas el
distanciamiento social y también por
supuesto lo que es la obligatoriedad del
lavado de manos que recordemos eran las
tres medias de barrera otro factor
santiago es lo que es la época del año
no sudamérica está comenzando el
invierno y en colombia esto se traduce
en una intensa época de lluvias que
habida por supuesto todo lo que son los
virus respiratorios y vamos a hablar
ahora de un tercer factor a tener en
cuenta de que es clave y es el descenso
en la inmunidad es que los anticuerpos
comienzan como ya sabemos trabajar a los
seis meses no luego de aplicada la
última dosis de la vacuna y muchas
personas por supuesto están llegando ya
a esta etapa y por eso han hecho énfasis
en las dosis de refuerzo santiago con
este panorama que usted nos describe y
también con ese ritmo que tiene colombia
en la vacunación las autoridades han
dicho que podrían estar a la vuelta de
la esquina de una nueva ola de contagios
en este país suramericano
así es santiago colombia efectivamente
como bien lo decías tiene un buen ritmo
en vacunación 22,60 santiago es el
porcentaje de la dosis de refuerzo
inocuidad por cada 100 habitantes estos
según números de principio de mes
en 28 días sólo ha reportado 75
fallecidos
pero los casos superan los 8 min en los
últimos 28 días y fernando ruiz hablamos
del ministro de salud colombiano explicó
que con el escenario actual es muy
probable que los casos aumenten mucho
más el ministro tomó como ejemplo lo que
está pasando en estados unidos donde la
variante omicron elevó de manera muy
considerable el nivel de los contagios a
la categoría alta ruiz dijo que colombia
debe estar atento al aumento de la
transmisión del coronavirus para por
supuesto tomar medidas preventivas para
una posible nueva ola un escenario que
las autoridades no descartan porque si
bien hay un mayor control de la
situación el virus con de nueva
circulando libremente y ahí como
decíamos menos restricciones
santiago hay un dato interesante de
colombia que ocupó el cuarto lugar en el
índice de normalidad global de la
revista the economist que mide los
países que se han recuperado esta crisis
sanitaria el kobe 19 según la más
reciente actualización en que se refleja
esto en el día a día y cuáles son las
categorías o los aspectos que tienen en
cuenta para esta evaluación bueno el
sentido como voz
deseas este índice de la normalidad
global de la revista the economist lo
que hace es medir a los países que
digamos están teniendo una recuperación
sanitaria del cob y 19 si bien colombia
tiene un destacado cuarto lugar hay que
decir que el país cayó cuatro posiciones
y representa un fuerte retroceso de
aquel destacadísimo primer lugar que
alcanzó en diciembre de 2021 no obstante
hay que decir colombia es uno de los
pocos países que rápidamente regresó a
indicadores y niveles de la época
prepandémica y en ese nivel están otros
países también que han sorprendido en
este índice hablamos por ejemplo de
egipto india y también de nigeria
el índice de normalidad global al que
estamos del que estamos hablando
califica ocho indicadores en tres
categorías hablamos de transporte
recreación y actividad comercial vale la
pena aclarar santiago que el estudio no
ha tenido en cuenta las medidas más
recientes hablamos por ejemplo de la
eliminación del uso de los tapabocas
para las poblaciones donde más del 70%
de los habitantes tienen una vacunación
completa y 40 por ciento de la población
nacional tiene dosis de refuerzo y hay
bajos niveles de contagio hay que
decirlo santiago la normalidad se
percibe fácilmente en las calles
colombianas el comercio está casi pleno
también está funcionando el transporte
público el sector aéreo y esto es muy
visible es visible en los cambios
colombianas muchas gracias santiago por
este reporte de la situación en colombia
hablamos ahora de la o ms que aprobó la
que sería la décimo primera vacuna que
estaría disponible en el mercado es
decir ya hay 11 disponibles en el
mercado mundial veamos de cual se trata
la organización mundial de la salud dio
luz verde a la vacuna anti cobit
convivencia' producida por la
farmacéutica china cancino nos complace
anunciar que nuestra vacuna convivencia
contra el kobe 19 recibió la lista de
uso de emergencia emitida por la
organización mundial de la salud
representando un hito importante para
cancino bayo y nuestros esfuerzos en la
lucha contra la pandemia de esta manera
se convirtió en la onceava vacuna en ser
aprobada por la o ms y la tercera
producida en el 'gigante asiático' junto
con sinovac y scinopharm se trata de la
segunda de la lista por detrás de la
vacuna jansen que requiere de una sola
dosis para un esquema completo de
vacunación según estudios este
inmunizante cuyo uso es sugerido para la
población mayor de 18 años tiene un 92
por ciento de eficacia contra el
desarrollo de formas graves de la
enfermedad y un
64% en cuanto a la protección contra
síntomas lo que le permite ser parte del
mecanismo kóvacs creado por la o ms en
cooperación con otras agencias para
distribuir a bajo precio y de forma
equitativa dosis de vacunas contra el
móvil 19
el mundo
el procedimiento de inclusión en la
lista de uso de emergencia de la oms
evalúa la calidad seguridad y eficacia
de las vacunas kobe 19 como requisito
previo para el suministro de la vacuna
kóvacs también permite a los países
acelerar su propia aprobación
reglamentaria para importar y
administrar las vacunas contra el kobe
otras vacunas que actualmente están en
sus últimos trámites para ser aprobadas
por la oms son la desarrollada por la
farmacéutica francesa sanofi y la china
claver by farmacéuticos que pronto
podrían salir al mercado
entre tanto las vacunas cubanas las
únicas producidas en latinoamérica como
la bda la soberana 2 y soberana plus
todavía no cuentan con la aprobación de
este organismo
aún así autoridades sanitarias de países
como méjico nicaragua y venezuela
aprobaron su uso en la población por su
parte irán está próxima a convertirse en
la primera nación en ser autorizada para
fabricar localmente el fármaco cubano
vamos a conocer la situación de perú nos
conectamos hasta lima con francisco
zacarías allí en la capital peruana
francisco gracias por acompañarnos y el
reporte de varios casos de dos de las
cinco sus variantes de omicron allí en
perú que dicen las autoridades
hola santiago el instituto nacional de
salud de ese país lanzó la alerta de
haber registrado las sus variantes ba1 a
ba2 circulando dentro del territorio
peruano el organismo reveló que se haya
identificado 182 casos de ba2 en 10
regiones del perú las autoridades
sanitarias se encuentran preocupadas por
que este total 6 pertenecen a la sub
variante beas 2 punto 12.1 científicos
locales afirman que este nuevo
descendiente de omicron podría generar
un rebrote de contagios estos seis
infectados son personas entre 22 y 64
años que viven en lima pero hasta ahora
no hay hospitalizados ni fallecidos por
ve a 2.12 punto 1 algunos expertos
afirman que si esta variante avanzará en
perú los adultos mayores las personas
con más de 2 enfermedades y quienes
padecen males crónicos correría mayor
peligro en esta línea crítica en el
desinterés que está teniendo la
población para vacunarse contra el kobe
19 señalan que mientras en el mundo se
avanza con la inoculación de la cuarta
dosis en este país sólo el 59 por ciento
de las personas cuentan tercera dosis
francisco allí en perú las autoridades
pronostican una cuarta ola que podría
producir 16.000 fallecidos durante ese
pico están tomando medidas para evitarlo
para el centro nacional de epidemiología
prevención y control de enfermedades una
posible cuarta ola del cobi 19 en el
peor escenario generaría 16 mil 996
muertes y 2.7 millones se contagiados
mientras que un panorama leve los
decesos serían cuatro mil 361 y los
infectados ascenderían a más de un ido
el ministerio de salud ha indicado que
una cuarta ola de la pandemia se
encuentra entre las probabilidades a
desarrollarse en los próximos meses los
funcionarios calculan que esto podría
iniciarse en la quincena de octubre y se
extendería hasta comienzos de 2023 ante
esta situación diversos expertos
recomiendan elevar la vacunación de la
tercera dosis a más del 70% de la
población para que el país se encuentre
más protegido y emplear estrategias de
prevención como reforzar las pruebas
antígenos para que las personas con
algún malestar puedan descartar si
tienen el coronavirus y de esta manera
evitar contagios masivos
francisco hablemos ahora de esa
exigencia a los ciudadanos de estar
vacunados para poder ejercer su derecho
al voto y también de las medidas que han
tomado
ante la amenaza que puede representar la
viruela del mono
la controversia surgió porque la oficina
nacional de procesos electorales ordenó
que para el sufragio de los ciudadanos
es obligatorio mostrar el carnet con las
tres dosis de la vacuna contra el hobbit
19 y quienes no lo tengan se restringe
su participación pues bien hace unos
días todos los partidos políticos
realizaron elecciones internas para los
candidatos a los comicios municipales y
regionales de octubre próximo y un
congresista protagonizó un incidente en
el exterior de su centro de votación
porque solo tenía las dos dosis de la
vacuna el legislador encendió la
polémica del derecho a la salud pública
versus el derecho al sufragio algunos
constitucionalistas aseguran que la
norma no es un abuso de autoridad y que
en este caso la libertad personal se
contrapone a la salud pública a la que
el gobierno prioriza por otro lado perú
declara la alerta sanitaria tras el
aumento de casos de la viruela del mono
en algunos países de europa y américa a
pesar que perú no tiene ningún caso el
ministro de salud jorge lópez afirmó que
la alerta es para prevenir cualquier
eventualidad por el momento las
autoridades no han decidido la compra de
vacunas pero así un monitoreo constante
en la población gracias francisco por
este reporte desde la ciudad de lima
vamos a hablar ahora de corea del norte
que vive un incremento exponencial en el
número de casos de kobe 19 cifras que
aparentemente este hermético país no
había registrado en poco más de una
semana más de 17 millones de personas
han sido contagiadas con lo que parece
ser kobe 19 pero que las autoridades
locales denominan como una simple fiebre
unas 62 personas ya han fallecido que es
una cifra que puede ser mucho más
elevada debido a la escasez de pruebas
de diagnóstico a las casas de
tratamientos y por supuesto de vacunas
en una reunión de emergencia del
politburó del gobernante partido de los
trabajadores para abordar los recientes
contagios por como el 19 en corea del
norte el presidente kim jong-un criticó
la respuesta irresponsable del estado de
cara al brote y acusó a funcionarios del
gobierno y al personal sanitario de
fracasos y negligencia a la hora de
actuar en respuesta ordenó a los
militares la distribución de
medicamentos alrededor de todo el
territorio nacional en cuanto llegamos
aquí empezamos a distribuir medicamentos
para los residentes
organizaciones internacionales como la
onu y human rights watch denunciaron que
en corea del norte los recursos para
testear diagnosticar y hacer frente al
virus son escasos y consideraron que las
medidas adoptadas para controlar el
virus como nuevas restricciones a los
viajes y el aislamiento de la población
podrían traer severas consecuencias
estamos profundamente preocupados por el
probable impacto en los derechos humanos
del primer brote oficial de kobe 19
instamos a las autoridades a que se
aseguren de que todas las medidas son
necesarias proporcionadas no
discriminatorias limitadas en el tiempo
y acordes con la legislación
internacional sobre los derechos humanos
corea del norte y eritrea son los dos
únicos países en el mundo que no cuentan
con un programa de vacunación contra el
coi 19 la comunidad internacional ha
instado a kim jong-un a abrir canales de
ayuda humanitaria para recibir
medicamentos y vacunas al tiempo que la
o ms y algunos países como china y la
república de corea se han ofrecido a
ayudar
si corea del norte responde a nuestra
ayuda animaremos en medicamentos
incluidas las vacunas contra el coi 19 y
en equipos médicos ni en personal
sanitario
en 2021 el país que lleva cerrado desde
2020 rechazó la donación de casi 5
millones de dosis según expertos jon
jiang no aceptará el envío de vacunas
porque implica recibir personal externo
que asesore las cadenas de frío para
distribuirlas sin embargo varios medios
han informado de aviones norcoreanos
cargando suministros en aeropuertos
chinos y mientras tanto en bolivia el
llamado de las autoridades a los
ciudadanos es a vacunarse con la cuarta
dosis de cualquiera de las vacunas
disponibles también se mantienen algunas
restricciones a nivel regional para
mitigar el aumento de casos que se están
registrando allí en la paz está meriva
acá con más detalles médico como siempre
un gusto saludarla y gracias por
acompañarnos en el programa y comienzo
preguntándole por las autoridades de
este país que están fomentando la
inoculación de esa cuarta dosis de
vacunas contra el kobe 19
hola qué tal santiago así es el gobierno
de luisa se ha pedido a los ciudadanos
bolivianos que concurran a hacerse
vacunar con la tercera y la cuarta dosis
en contra del coronavirus luego de que
se registrara en el país la llegada de
la variante ba2 de omicron y que esto
coincidiera con un incremento de casos
de kobe 19 el gobierno ha informado que
hasta la fecha se han comprado más de 23
millones de vacunas pero se han colocado
sólo 13 millones de estas vacunas por
eso es importante dijo el gobierno que
la gente concurra a inmunizarse con la
tercera y la cuarta dosis respecto a los
índices de vacunación hay que decir que
en casa en el caso de adultos y de
personas de la tercera edad éste está
por encima del 60% sin embargo donde
existe preocupación es en el grupo
etario de jóvenes y niños donde los
índices están entre el 30 y el 40 por
ciento mary revisando las cifras vemos
que al igual que muchos países de la
región hay una tendencia al incremento
de cifras bolivia está registrando
precisamente un aumento de casos de
contagio de kobe 19 que dicen las
autoridades allí
así es en la última semana se ha
producido un incremento inusual de casos
de kobe 19 subiendo de 300 a 700 casos a
nivel nacional lo que ha causado una
profunda preocupación del gobierno pues
dice que en el mes de junio podrían
llegar la quinta ola de kobe 19 y esto
podría ser acelerado o empeorado por la
llegada del invierno al país en bolivia
hasta la fecha durante toda la pandemia
se han presentado más de 900 mil casos
de kobe 19 y según las cifras oficiales
los fallecidos están a punto de llegar a
los 22 mil aunque según cifras
extraoficiales los muertos están en el
triple de lo que establecen las cifras
oficiales
mary con este aumento de los casos las
autoridades piden a las autoridades
regionales mantener las restricciones
cuales se mantienen entonces
frente a este incremento de casos el
gobierno ha prohibido a los gobiernos
municipales y departamentales que
relajen el uso de barbijos hay que decir
que algunas regiones estaban a punto de
suspender la obligatoriedad de usar la
mascarilla en los lugares abiertos pero
finalmente todos tendrán que seguir
usando barbijo en bolivia precisamente
por este incremento de casos y por la
llegada de la nueva variante en cuanto a
viajes en bolivia ya no se pide la
prueba pcr para el ingreso al país pero
en cambio se exige el carnet de
vacunación del esquema completo por otro
lado se mantiene la emergencia sanitaria
en bolivia pero las actividades son
prácticamente normales y presenciales
por ejemplo las escuelas universidades
en los centros deportivos y también las
actividades festivas
muchas gracias medio por este reporte
desde la ciudad de la paz en bolivia y
mientras tanto el ecuador hay también
polémica por el entorno al uso de las
mascarillas a nivel nacional también las
autoridades advirtieron sobre el aumento
de casos que se está presentando en
diferentes regiones como lo ven ya son
varios países los que están en la misma
situación vamos hasta quitó allí está a
gustavo ortega gustavo allí el
ministerio de salud asumió entonces el
control del uso de las mascarillas
porque había discrepancias con los
gobiernos locales
hola que tal sentido un saludo del uso
de las mascarillas en ecuador se ha
convertido en un tema de disputas
políticas entre el ejecutivo nacional y
algunas de las autoridades municipales
tal es el caso de la ciudad costera de
guayaquil donde sus autoridades han
decidido no acatar el levantamiento de
la medida de uso obligatorio desde los
cubrebocas en guayaquil se ha dispuesto
que el uso de las mascarillas en
espacios cerrados se extenderá hasta el
27 de mayo el comité de operaciones de
emergencia organismo encargado de
administrar el manejo de la pandemia en
el país andino ha pedido a las
autoridades regionales que comuniquen y
cumplan con esta decisión del ejecutivo
nacional y ha expresado preocupación en
este sentido el ministerio de salud
alertó a las autoridades locales que
éste es el órgano competente para tomar
la política de salud del país y podrían
verse sancionados de omitir la nueva
regulación el gobierno intenta frenar
las conclusiones entre los ciudadanos
ante las posibles sanciones de tipo
económico al no saber si quitarse o no
quitarse los tapabocas en el país
autoridad nacional aseguró que no tiene
conocimiento bajo qué normativa las
ciudades como guayaquil o cuenca es
sancionarán a los ciudadanos por no
quitarse las mascarillas 4 cantones del
país todavía no acatan la medida de
eliminar el uso de los cubrebocas en los
espacios abiertos en tres regiones la
provincia de guayas y una en la
provincia de cuenca esto representa el
2% los 221 cantones que no han levantado
la obligatoriedad de la medida emitida
por el gobierno nacional bueno ha
gustado sigue siendo un poco confuso el
uso del tapabocas y por eso en quito en
la capital el nacional donde usted está
los ciudadanos siguen con temor no saben
si usar o no usar el tapabocas muchos
las siguen usando en el ámbito público
cuál es la normativa entonces vigente la
capital
si efectivamente lo de casi un mes de
levantada la medida de uso obligatorio
en espacios abiertos y cerrados el
ecuador se maneja entre el alivio de ya
no tener que usar las mascarillas luego
de dos años de restricciones sanitarias
a causa de la pandemia y el temor de
quienes desconfían de la decisión del
ejecutivo nacional pero por qué se
genera este ambiente es que el país
andino también enfrenta a una escasez de
medicamentos en los principales
hospitales red pública de salud además
también coincide con una feria de
técnica que ha suspendido la situación
de turnos para las atenciones médicas en
los servicios sociales de salud hay que
conocer también que la disposición
presidencial del ejecutivo quiere
priorizar la recuperación económica pero
esto ha generado el incremento de aforos
también del 100 por ciento en todas las
actividades los que muchos sienten temor
ante esta recuperación y aforos en la
ciudad en espacios abiertos centros
comerciales autobuses la imagen de
personas utilizando los tapabocas es
habitual en algunas ciudades del país
también originado ante la posibilidad de
volver al uso de las mascarillas en
algunas ciudades de los eeuu los
rebrotes de la pandemia en asia y sobre
todo el recuerdo de lo que vivió el país
como en cadáveres en las calles durante
los primeros meses de la pandemia en
ecuador esto todavía hace dudar a muchos
ecuatorianos de quitarse o no las
mascarillas o dejarlas en casa y
respirar libremente como invito al
presidente de este país guillermo lasso
hace casi un mes
gustavo hablemos entonces del panorama
general de ecuador y me llama la
atención guayaquil que sigue siendo el
foco de contagio en este país
suramericano como es el panorama general
si efectivamente existe un ligero
aumento de casos confirmados de kobe 19
en el país reconoció la ministra de
salud cimera garzón en un balance
semanal que adelanta esta cartera de
estado tenía explicó que estos casos no
han requerido atención médica u
hospitalización y se mantienen los
niveles de positividad del 3% en guayas
y 5% en pichincha a regiones con mayor
concentración de habitantes en el país
andino según la titular de salud se
trataría de personas que han dado
positivo por sospechas y síntomas al
realizarse una prueba de pcr aseguró que
la mayoría la mayoría de los cuadros
médicos son leves tanto en la ciudad
capital ecuatoriana como en la ciudad
costera de guayaquil existen ligeros
incrementos de casos pero también
aseguró que no existe demanda de
unidades de cuidados intensivos y pocas
demandas de camas de hospitalización en
este país por octava semana ecuador
mantiene un índice de positividad viral
del 4 por ciento en pruebas de antígeno
y finalmente alertó que existe un
defecto o sesgo en la recolección de las
muestras de peces por ello se modificará
a los lineamientos para los museos
comunitarios
gustavo muchas gracias por este
completísimo reporte desde quito la
capital ecuatoriana y vamos a terminar
nuestro programa dando un vistazo a
otras noticias relacionadas con la
pandemia que están destacadas en redes y
es una noticia que reiteramos la publica
el diario chicago tribune titula la ope
se advierte sobre el aumento de casos de
kobe 19 en américa la pandemia continúa
la ope se alertó sobre este aumento de
casos y muertes por kobe 19 en las
últimas cuatro semanas las
hospitalizaciones aumentaron en 18
países y las admisiones en terapia
intensiva también aumentaron en 13
países y territorios este organismo
internacional indicó que hay que tener
en cuenta los números para poder actuar
y así llegamos al final de kobe 19 la
semana en américa nos encontramos la
próxima semana pueden seguir viendo
france24 nos vemos hasta pronto
[Música]